hi my name is Craig Barron and I want to
introduce John Fraser he's a special
effects man and he's going to tell us
about how to make snow in the movies
snow over the years has evolved into
several different things and mainly it
evolves around the environment and as
we've progressed in the years we've
learned that some of the stuff that
we've used early on it's not quite
user-friendly they were at that time
still playing with the idea of using
bleached cornflakes and just any
elements that they could find it would
look like snow whether it be calcium
chloride which is just ground up Tom's
which we found out later on is it's not
healthy when it's in the air the problem
with the bleach cornflakes is that it
became a health hazard when you're
shooting at Warner Brothers behind
Griffith Park he didn't want the deers
running down into your set getting the
cornflakes so we stopped the cornflakes
Russell Sherman at that time it was an
excellent special effects man came up
with the idea of using a product called
for Mike and what he would do is he
would mix that with a little bit of
water and a little bit of soap and it
would get foamy and he's playing around
with it and he takes that foam that he
has and he threw it in front of a small
fan well this is great we can use this
for falling snow so from that Russell
took that from the little fan and a
little bit of soap and now he made it in
55-gallon drums and we and he put it in
front of really big fans like this and
he was able to create that effect on the
back lot where they did that famous snow
scene that you see at the end of the
movie that snow all you see that snow
falling with at that time was in those
early days even that foam and that snow
was biodegradable that started a whole
new era of making snow for us and I
think they did mention that we also gave
Russell a scientific achievement award
for that creating that effect and behind
this this foam generator which you'll
see later on is Ritter fan the Ritter
fan is named by from Bob Ritter who
invented the fan the fan blade it looks
like a typically or ordinary fan blade
except that it's got eight blades it's
got a tip on the end and
reason for this tip on the end this is
the family that's turning around the
sound that's generated through the
family and it would go on through all
the sound that you hear from a fan blade
is at the tip this blade is only used in
motion picture work and the reason for
that it has it doesn't it wouldn't work
for anything else that only works for
making movies commercials TV shows
because of the blade this blade allows
it for not to have any other that it
cuts it deadens the sound of the blade
itself what this what we use the fans
for typically is just to augment or
enhance whatever it we're blowing like
say if it's in this case it's no which
would come out of the blower here it's
only going to go straight up